many of the news channels put up
information sidebars to explain who's
speaking
you know like whom someone's talking
they put up this information and that's
what I need to know what's happening
like this one with congresswoman Jackie
Speier they just put up this information
you look at it you go oh yeah okay that
makes sense great I'm on board this is
where I found I was watching it today
and as the hearings went on the stuff
they put up was less and less helpful to
me that's what I notice and that's why
you should have been watching you have
noticed the same thing for example Ohio
Congressman Jim Jordan checked us out it
says glasses regularly slide his nut
down his nose to get away from head
lopped his twin brother to death in the
womb thinks the clitoris is a winged
horse from Greek mythology didn't
understand why that I mean I'm with them
on the third one look at this one
Committee Chairman Adam Schiff check it
out can wear a wedding band as a
necklace has had the same hair line
since age 11 favorite snack is dipping
unsalted pretzels in warm water
yeah check this one out Texas
congressman John Ratcliffe face was put
together in a hurry as a child dreamed
of one day becoming a subscriber to Golf
Digest calls zippers gateways to sin
Democrat Mike Quigley check it out
office filled with high school wrestling
trophies holds the Guinness record for
the most bugs accidentally swallowed
sits in a little fire truck when he gets
a haircut
congressman Denny heck yeah doesn't need
to be asleep to snore picturing audience
in their underwear makes him more
nervous cried at paul blart mall cop to
house Republican Attorney Steve castor
able to chew through wires and plastic
pipes for first to leave droppings and
vents and sewers has pups in litters of
6 to 12 and finally congressman Devin
Nunez tried to have a man arrested for
not joining his LinkedIn thought Stephen
Hawking was faking it saves money on
viagra by yelling at penis it doesn't
work